a nuestras espaldas se ubica el campo de
refugiados palestino de swafat que acaba
de abrirse tras cinco días de bloqueo
por las fuerzas israelíes este cierre
que imposibilitaba la entrada y salida
de bienes y personas también se extendió
a Nata una localidad cercana y anabús al
norte de cisjordania por las mismas
razones Y es que Israel aseguraba Buscar
a los responsables palestinos de las
muertes de dos soldados en dos ataques
diferentes uno el sábado aquí en
Jerusalén y otro el martes en navús sin
embargo estos bloqueos han sido
denunciados como un castigo colectivo
hacia los palestinos Pues solo en su
afat Residen más de 100.000 personas la
respuesta del campo de refugiados fue
una desobediencia civil que este
miércoles se tradujo en una especie de
huelga solidaria de escuelas y comercios
a lo largo de cisjordania y que hasta
esta madrugada fue seguida de protestas
en varios barrios de Jerusalén este
ocupado algunas derivaron en duros
enfrentamientos mientras los
manifestantes palestinos arro con
piedras e incendieron contenedores de
basura las fuerzas israelíes
respondieron con gases lacrimógenos y
granadas aturdidoras además de con la
detención de 24 palestinos en Jerusalén
este y cisjordania pesa la apertura de
este campo de refugiados esta violencia
no se había visto en Jerusalén este
desde mayo de 2021 y a su vez las
redadas ya restos israelíes solo Están
yendo en aumento con al menos 116
muertos palestinos en cisjordania en lo
que va de